Welcome to the White Lotus
in Sicily.
Let's do this!
MIKE WHITE: Last season
really got into privilege,
and this season's more of a
kind of bedroom farce
with teeth.
(KNOCKING ON DOOR)
Buona sera.
It's about how awkward
we all are,
and how sexual tension prevents
us from knowing each other,
and being able
to accept each other.
There's a plot strand
that's about toxic masculinity
and trying to break the cycle.
THEO JAMES:
Everyone is functioning in a way
to manipulate or undercut
another character.
I'm not a fool.
Stop flirting with my wife.
ADAM DIMARCO: Some of the themes
are infidelity, family bonding,
murder. (LAUGHS)
It's kind of got everything.
Season two is decidedly sexier
than season one.
Also, the environment
lends itself
to that romantic, summer vibe.
I think Sicily
is the perfect place
for romance and sexual politics.
BEATRICE GRANNÓ:
Taormina is so special.
It's an out of time place,
and you feel like
you're in this bubble.
MIKE: When we saw
the Four Seasons
in Taormina,
it was just such
a beautiful location,
and it just sold this
kind of old world,
European summer vacation.
The first season,
we were lucky to work with
such an eclectic range
of actors.
I really wanted to duplicate
that again this season.
JON GRIES: Any time I shoot
with Jennifer Coolidge,
the hardest part
is to keep my concentration
and not to laugh.
(COUGHING)
(GROANS) I swallowed a bug.
The great thing about season two
is Tanya really gets to
come out of her shell.
What if I take a look
in the mirror,
and then just, like, bite my arm
really hard?
-(LAUGHTER)
-Maybe not that.
(YELLS PLAYFULLY)
Mike White. (LAUGHS)
He brings a positive energy.
To me, Mike, he's a maestro.
He can make you laugh and cry
about life in the same time.
WILL SHARPE:
I'm so impressed with how
his scripts spin so many plates.
He takes care of
all the different characters
in the ensemble
and weaves the stories together.
HALEY LU RICHARDSON:
We're all a protagonist
to our own story,
and antagonist to someone else.
Mike can write characters
that don't have a lot
of redeeming qualities,
and he gives them a break.
MICHAEL IMPERIOLI:
It's a great company of people
who like each other,
and like what they're doing,
and are proud
of what they're doing.
You bond on a set like this
because there's no way out.
The true romance for me
of this production
is just getting to have
this experience
with people that would end up
becoming close friends
and having this intense,
collaborative experience.